[Music]
hi guys it's quinn here if you enjoy my
channel consider hitting the like button
it's the only way the youtube algorithm
really notices me
it's not every day that i
love
a book series and i read a lot of book
series
especially science fiction ever since i
read the three body problem series aka
the remembrance of earth's past trilogy
i have not been able to stop thinking
about it
the scale of this series is enormous the
ominous mysteries that it invokes are
intriguing and chilling to the core now
i've made a few videos on this series
and you can find those linked in a
playlist in the description in this
video we will discuss some of the major
events detailed in book 2 the dark
forest the great ravine and the
tricelerian invasion of the solar system
by the year 205 of the crisis era
humanity at large believed that they had
nothing to fear from the tri-soleran
fleet which had more than 200 years
before it would reach our solar system
fear of the tricelerans whose sofon
technology had crippled humankind's
understanding of physics and allowed the
aliens real-time knowledge of events on
earth had once nearly destroyed humanity
plunging them into a devastating period
of time known as the great ravine
one might be tempted to compare the
great ravine to the depression of 1930
but the great ravine and nowhere
compares to the great depression
it is far worse
and the year 1930 there were about 2
billion people on earth at the start of
the great ravine there were 8.3 billion
people on earth and when there was no
more food
billions starved
i have seen the grand march of hunger
millions of people fleeing famine on the
great plains through sand that blocked
out the sky
hot sky hot earth and hot sun
when they died they were divided up on
the spot
it was hell on earth there are tons of
videos to watch if you want
the great ravine awakened the worst of
humanity cannibalism and obscene
violence
mankind became a gaggle of desperate
animals fighting for scraps of food and
resources
we had pushed mother earth to her
breaking point and the dried-up world
could no longer provide
the great ravine was brought on by
several things the increasingly hostile
political climate brought on by the
knowledge of alien existence and their
intended invasion as well as humans
growing hopeless due to the feeling that
there was nothing that they could do to
prevent the invasion were among the
contributors but the biggest factor in
causing the great ravine was the change
of climate
which was sped on by the creation of the
space force since the concept of
escapism had been banned globally the
world focused tremendous resources on
the development of planetary defense
the space force's creation and
maintenance heavily polluted the
atmosphere
raising the temperature of the earth
tremendously desertification began
rapidly all over the earth at once
eventually food could not be grown the
great ravine lasted 50 years and during
that time the vast majority of humans on
earth died
the population decreased from 8.3
billion to 3.5 billion the great ravine
had been a time of tremendous suffering
for humankind
famine on a level never seen before
up until this point the great ravine was
the lowest point in human history
for many it must have felt like the end
of the human race but it was merely a
crucible
humankind had been brought through it to
appear on the other side
after the population of the earth
drastically decreased society eventually
began to restabilize but this was only
after the remaining people decided that
perhaps the price they were paying to
win the doomsday battle
was too high
the people of earth had to choose to
focus on the present
rather than what is to come
there was a revolution new governments
were formed the space strategies
terminated
humanity poured its attention into
improving the lives of people
eventual crucial technology like genetic
engineering and fusion technology
emerged
large-scale food production was no
longer dependent on weather
humankind entered a new golden age
after about 50 years of peace following
the great ravine humanity again turned
its thoughts to the tricelarines and
their fleet which still approached earth
a global state of war was redeclared and
production of the space force begin
again this time however with the more
conditional trajectory of resource
expenditure as well as an assurance that
work on the space force was to under no
circumstance have a harsh impact on the
world economy and community life
the space fleets of the world became
independent countries with a central
governing body known as fleet
international by the year 205 of the
crisis era about a hundred years after
the great ravine humankind had been
renewed with confidence
ironically the space force whose
construction had led to the climate
conditions that had exacerbated human
suffering during the great ravine was by
the year 205 of the crisis era the
reason that humans were now confident
that their own technology had surpassed
the tricelerians or was at least
sufficient to thwart them they were
convinced that they could never again
return to the chaos of the great ravine
humankind's exponential technological
development was something the
tricelerians had acknowledged and feared
sofon technology could limit it in many
aspects but not outright stop it
space vessels of this era were enormous
three times the size of the largest sea
going carriers of the 21st century
the giant spacecraft equal in volume to
three of the largest sea going carriers
of the 21st century was practically a
small city
but it had no bridge or command module
or even a captain's room or operations
room in fact it had no specific
functional compartments whatsoever
all of them were identical regular
spears that differed only in size
at any location inside the ship you
could just use a data glove to activate
a holographic display which due to the
high cost was a rarity even in earth's
super wired society and at any location
so long as you had the appropriate
system permissions you could pull up a
complete command console including a
captain's interface which effectively
made the entire ship even the
passageways and bathrooms a bridge
command module captain's room and
operations room
technology had made incredible leaps and
bounds and ships of this day were
simplistic to operate given that one
possessed proper permissions
operations on board ships were
essentially automatic requiring minimal
input to initiate
under maximum acceleration the best of
humanity's fleet could reach 120 g's
obviously a force far greater than what
a human body could withstand without
being crushed because of this the crew
would have to enter a deep sea state
essentially cabins would be filled with
an oxygen-rich fluid which trained
professionals could breathe directly
a ship would not enter ultra
acceleration mode unless it detected
that the crew was in a deep sea state
pressure was an equilibrium inside and
outside of a human body filled with deep
sea acceleration fluid meaning it could
sustain high pressures like a deep sea
fish
the environment of a liquid-filled cabin
in a rapidly accelerating spacecraft was
like that of the deep sea so the liquid
was now being used to protect human
bodies against the ultra acceleration of
space travel hence the term deep sea
state
the space force now consisted of
thousands of powerful fusion-filled
warships equipped with lasers of immense
destructive capabilities the
technological development of the space
fleet was however not the only reason
for humanity's confidence that the
tri-salons were no longer a severe
threat to human society on earth
after passing through dust clouds the
tricelerian fleet had begun to slow down
after passing through several of such
clouds over the course of its
two-century journey into our solar
system it had lost its formation
entirely
the trisolarens have however launched an
object
which is nearing our solar system
some believe the object was a military
probe but there was a growing sentiment
held by many people that it was a gift
from the tricelerians a metaphorical
white flag communicating surrender or
perhaps a willingness to negotiate
the belief that the tricelerians would
seek to negotiate was common in this era
for the tricelerians would know of the
current state of humanity's
technological development
when humanity received the object within
the solar system it did not
self-destruct as they expected it would
had it been a military probe
they were then certain that it was a
gift and the beauty of the object did
nothing to dispel this idea the probe
was a perfect teardrop shape
round at the head and pointy at the tail
with the surface so smooth it was a
total reflector
the milky way was reflected on its
surface as a smooth pattern of light
that gave the mercury droplet a pure
beauty
its droplet shape was so natural that
observers imagined it in a liquid state
one for which an internal structure was
impossible because of the droplet
people's opinions of the tricelerians
began to change
humanity began to recognize that the
tricelerians were like themselves a
great civilization enduring the cold and
uncaring cosmos in search of a stable
home
the public's opinion of the tricelerians
began to change from hatred to sympathy
and even admiration the existence of the
tricelerians meant we were not alone in
the universe perhaps we could have a
friend among the stars the u.n and the
fleets accelerated their preparations
for negotiations and the two
internationals began organizing
delegations
all of this took place in the day after
the droplet was captured
but what excited the people most of all
was not the facts before their eyes but
the rudimentary outline of a bright
future what sort of fantastic paradise
would the solar system become after the
union of tricelerian technology and
human power
the droplet was incredibly dense as if
the molecules had been nailed into place
it had no vibrations it was completely
solid and because of this the object's
temperature actually read at absolute
zero
the droplet was a marvel of technical
engineering which demonstrated a scope
of technological advancement that
humankind had not breached yet in normal
matter the separation between nuclei in
separate atoms is actually quite large
to squeeze them together as they were in
the droplet would require obscene force
far beyond the capabilities of humanity
this was their first hint that something
was deeply wrong
but by then it was already far too late
the droplet was not fragile like a tear
entirely the opposite
its strength was a hundred times greater
than the sturdiest material in the solar
system
all known substances were as fragile as
paper by comparison
it could pass through the earth like a
bullet through cheese without even the
slightest harm to its surface
then
what's it here for the lieutenant
colonel blurted out who knows
maybe it really is just a messenger
but is here to give humanity a different
message
dingy said turning his gaze away from
the droplet
what
if i destroy you
what business is it of yours
suddenly the droplet moved
and when it moved it moved incredibly
fast
the four members of the expedition team
which had received the droplet were
annihilated immediately
the human fleet which was watching from
a thousand kilometers away
initially read this as the droplet
self-destructing they felt sorrow for
the four they had lost and disappointed
that the droplet was not in fact a
messenger of peace
but nothing could have prepared the
human race for what happened next
within 51 seconds from the time of the
explosion the droplet had already flown
1500 kilometers and now approached the
corner of the space force's formation
by this point neither the space force
nor its computer systems had
comprehended that the droplet had not
been destroyed in the initial explosion
the computer systems did not register
the droplet as a physical object as its
movements were seemingly impossible
it was moving at twice the third cosmic
velocity executing precise sharp turns
without any drop in speed
such force would completely flatten a
normal object the droplet with its
incredible force begins to pass through
the ships of the space fleet
after passing through infinite frontier
the droplet continued onward at a speed
of 30 kilometers per second
in the space of three seconds it had
crossed 90 kilometers passing through
young fan
infinite frontier's neighbor in the
first row and then through foghorn
antarctica and ultimate leaving their
holes red hot as if the warships were
giant lamps lined up
this triggered a kind of chain reaction
each of the ships had been hit in the
fusion fuel tanks nuclear fireballs
illuminated the entire fleet against the
smooth blackness of space
in precisely one minute and 18 seconds
the droplet had passed through the 100
ships in the first row of the space
force's formation
leaving a trail of metallic magma adrift
in space
as the droplet approached the second row
the fleet still did not understand what
was happening the sheer amount of
information they had received in the
last 80 seconds or so had only been
analyzable by the computer system which
had finally falsely determined that a
powerful enemy space force had appeared
and launched an attack on the fleet the
computer could provide no information
about the enemy the droplet was
invisible to every means of detection
they possessed and was far faster than
they had the capability to deal with
by this time
fleet commanders were in a state of num
shock
for nearly two centuries research into
space strategy and tactics had dreamed
up every possible kind of extreme battle
condition
but witnessing a hundred warships
blowing up like a string of firecrackers
in under a minute was beyond what their
minds could comprehend
the tide of information surging out of
the battle information system meant that
they were forced to rely on the analysis
and judgment of the computer battlefield
decision-making system and focused their
attention on detecting an invisible
enemy fleet that didn't even exist all
battle monitoring capacity was directed
into the distant regions of space
ignoring the danger right in front of
them a fair number of people believed
that the powerful invisible enemy might
be a third-party alien force distinct
from humanity and trisolaris because in
their subconscious minds trisolaris
remained the weaker losing side
the scattering of superheated debris
caused by these explosions further added
to the confusion of this event the
computers misconceived the presence of
this debris as an indication that the
fleet was engaged in exchange of fire
with an enemy space force everyone
believed the droplet had already been
destroyed
when the droplet moved to destroy the
second row of ships they were all still
aligned the droplets surged and in one
minute and 20 seconds the second row of
100 ships had been annihilated
the droplet took two minutes and 35
seconds to destroy the third row of
ships
the ships in this row had begun to
activate their defensive systems and
were slightly misaligned but it made
little difference
thirteen minutes of destruction went on
before the fleet command system finally
arrived at the correct assessment
various scenarios for the doomsday
battle had been concocted during the two
centuries of study of space strategy but
in the minds of strategists the enemy
had always been big
humanity would meet the main part of the
mighty tricelerian force on a space
battlefield with every warship a
fortress of death the size of a small
city they had imagined every extreme
form of weapons and tactics the enemy
could possibly possess
the most terrifying of which involved
the tricelerian fleet launching an
attack using anti-matter weapons and
obliterating a stellar-class battleship
with anti-matter the size of a rifle
bullet but now the combined fleet had to
face facts
their only enemy was a tiny probe
one drop of water out of the enormous
ocean of tri-solar and strength and this
probe attacked using one of the oldest
and most primitive tactics known to
human navies
ramming considering the complexity of
the situation and the sheer volume of
information the fleet command system
assessed the problem relatively quickly
it just wasn't quick enough
the droplet itself was too quick in that
short time it had destroyed more than
600 warships
a devastating reality washed over
everyone who had the potential to
conceive the truth of the situation
command of a space battle was beyond
their reach
and because of sofon technology it was
beyond the reach of their artificial
intelligence as well
humanity would likely never have the
capacity to engage in battle with
trisolaris
purely in terms of command
they simply could not react fast enough
in 20 minutes
half the fleet roughly 1 000 ships had
been completely destroyed
the remaining 1000 ships were scattered
trapped in an expanding cloud of heated
debris
at this point the droplet speed was 10
times the third cosmic velocity moving
at 170 kilometers per second
its course took it smashing through
debris that liquefied under impact
splashing away at high speed to collide
with other debris and giving the droplet
a brilliant tail
first it resembled a comet bristling
with rage
but as the tail lengthened it turned
into a huge silver dragon that stretched
ten thousand kilometers
the entire metallic cloud glowed with
the dragon's light as it whipped to and
fro in its mad dance
the warships penetrated by the dragon's
head begin to explode along its body so
that it was dotted with the nuclear
explosions of four or five small suns at
any given time
further back molten battleships became
multi-million ton metallic magma
explosions that died its tale of
bewitching blood red
30 minutes later
not a single ship remained in the cloud
all but 21 ships had escaped the cloud
but the droplet went after them too
intending to complete its massacre
quickly it had hunted them down and
destroyed them humanity's space force in
the end had been useless against
tricelerian technology
nine trisolaren probes presumably just
like the one that had destroyed the
entirety of humanity's space force would
arrive within the solar system within
three years
with the destruction of the space force
human society once again collapsed into
chaos
they had been lulled into a false sense
of security
only to have it dashed away brutally in
a devastating instant
the annihilation of the human race
seemed almost certain at this point
that was until luogie a relic of a past
governmental program known as the
wallfacer project committed the actions
which would lead to the deterrence era
we will discuss the deterrence era and
the events leading up to it in another
video
the droplets massacre and how deeply
unprepared humanity is for it in this
book forces us to consider the things
that we are unprepared for in our
society like humanity in this era of the
series we are also overconfident that
our technology will rectify our future
problems
like climate change or overpopulation
and we are overconfident that the
societal structures that we have created
will remain stable indefinitely
there are a countless number of ways our
society could
recollapse into a dark age
disease nuclear weapons a cosmic threat
like an asteroid
our society
our existence is neither guaranteed nor
stable
also like the humanity during this era
in the book we live mostly comfortable
lives
that comfort often adds to the illusion
of safety and stability
and quite frankly sometimes it is just
easier to believe that the future will
be good
based on little evidence at all
and disregard totally the information
that suggests otherwise
this leaves us utterly unready when
unavoidable problems suddenly occur the
journey for humanity does not end here
however
for humanity in the series i mean as for
the real world i guess nobody knows
if you like my videos consider following
me on twitter also help me out by
hitting the like button if you're
interested in more about this series or
some other cool sci-fi books check out
the rest of my channel where i cover
some of my favorite science fiction
stories
now that i still have you here i guess
i'll tell you about some of the science
fiction books that i read recently
the first one is the labyrinth i saw
this in a bookstore and i just had to
have it this one's awesome because it
relies on a lot of visual storytelling
which as a lover of graphic novels i
really enjoy
this can kind of be thought of as a
different kind of graphic novel
it has a really heavy sci-fi aesthetic
but that's really just in the background
to what is ultimately a very
simple story
about vengeance and crimes against
humanity and the things that the
perpetrators of those crimes tell
themselves to justify them i'll just
show you guys a little bit of this
beautiful art
[Music]
so i definitely recommend this for
anybody that's into the sci-fi aesthetic
and also just like simple story don't go
into this expecting some grand
action adventure or some like crazy
mystery because this really is just kind
of a simple story but really really good
next up is children of time
which i freaking
loved
i can't say too much about this one
without spoiling a bunch but it's not
for an arachnophobe essentially this one
is about human hubris and evolution and
what is selfhood and what is
consciousness there's a lot of really
cool concepts squeezed into this one but
this is one of the most fun science
fiction books that i've read in a really
long time it's also really deep it's
really smart and it just is a page
turner when i got it i could not put it
down i read it in a couple of days
so this one's really good and i will
talk about this one more on my channel
and the future and there actually is a
sequel which i'm reading now called
children of ruin which continues uh in
this same world so that's really really
awesome
thank you guys so much for hanging out
with me on my youtube channel my own
graphic novel tadia exordium goes back
on sale for the general public on march
20th that's when you can pick that up on
my website quinnhoward.net thank you
guys so much